for the love of god please compliment
the person that you like
genuinely compliment them if you like a
guy they probably don't get compliments
all that often so when you do say
something nice
they're gonna eat it up and it's gonna
stick with them a lot longer but if you
like a girl they probably get a little
bit more compliments so you have to make
it stand out don't just say hey i like
your shoes say hey
i really like how you wear your hair
down like that it looks really good or
like hey i really like the color of that
shirt
it makes your eyes pop psychology tricks
on how to get your crush to like you
back that i know work
because i use them if you're having a
face-to-face conversation with your
crush
make eye contact and smile i'm telling
you guys i told you last time
smiling will change your life it's going
to show them that you're interested
and listening to them which is going to
get you some points want to know how to
tell if somebody has a crush on you
there's usually a lot of subtle signs in
somebody's body language and if you know
what to look for
they're like dead giveaways like if
somebody really likes you they're gonna
unconsciously copy your mannerisms
use that to your advantage you might
also catch this person looking at you
a lot like a lot a lot and if somebody
likes you they're gonna be laughing at
everything you say and i can promise you
you're not that funny
but they think you are so like people
also really like to be in close
proximity with the people that they like
so somebody has a crush on you they're
gonna try and be around you all
the time and if they have open body
language and their feet are facing you
in a conversation oh
ah they don't like you bro and i mean
bro in like the most gender neutral way
don't flip out
and honestly if you're asking yourself
if somebody likes you you probably
already know it in your gut like you
either have that vibe that somebody's
drawn to you
or you don't this next one is super easy
just ask them questions get your crush
talking about themselves because
everybody likes to talk about themselves
it's going to make them think
that you actually wanna know about them
which you should you like them
plus it's gonna make them feel more
connected to you because they're opening
up and sharing a part of themselves
plus if they ask questions back this is
a great
great sign that they're interested back
even if it's just a little bit
the bandwagon effect is a little bit
more manipulative but if you're
desperate
it might work so get a friend or two to
mention in front of your crush how cool
or attractive they think you are
studies have shown that people will be
more attracted to you if they think
other people think you're attractive
the best advice that i've ever gotten is
to treat your crush like you would a new
acquaintance you don't meet somebody new
and then immediately expect
daily texts or hanging out once a week
or you don't overthink like everything
you do and say around them and this is
exactly how you should treat your crush
because it's going to help you relax a
little bit it's going to show you you're
not completely obsessed with this person
even if you are
and it's going to make all these other
tricks a lot easier if you just don't
overthink it this sounds obvious but not
everybody does it
take the extra steps to be attractive
work out eat right do your hair nobody's
going to fall in love with you when
you're walking around targeting your pjs
and flip-flops if you act
super excited every time you see
somebody they're eventually going to be
really excited to see you back and not
even know why
you could also take this the next step
further and figure out your crush's
favorite type of candy
and then give them that candy every time
you see them if you do this enough
eventually even after you stop giving
them candy they're still going to have
that subconscious reaction
to be very happy to see you you need to
show subtle signs that you're interested
in this person be able to spark an
interest back in you
so like if there's a dance or a party or
something and they ask you oh hey are
you going
say something along the lines of like oh
only if you're going it's gonna show
that you like being around them and it's
definitely gonna bubble up some
questions within themselves
this one might come off as obvious but
just like be you don't try to be
somebody that you think your crush
might like because it's gonna come off
as way more genuine if you just let your
personality shine through rather than
trying to act like somebody you're not
besides your personality is what's gonna
make you likeable and those little
quirks that you have
are usually what somebody likes the most
about you
you